big question off the top Peter Webber
announces The Bachelor
there was a rallying cry Derek Peck for
bachelor one of the people I was
captivated by your story in Paradise and
you know we've had a fandom for a long
time how did you feel about hearing
Peters name announced I think Peters
gonna do an awesome job he seemed sure I
have a great head on your shoulder and
seems like he's going about you know his
search for love the right way
I was just mind blown that anybody would
put me in that sentence so I didn't
expect anything but wish the best for
him was it ever discussed with producer
that it was not officially discussed
unofficially perhaps a text or two I
that's not a it's a text or two question
with screen shots is that you're asking
for we heard a lot of bad stuff about
screen shots tonight let's talk about
Blake because not the finale taping you
said do just say you're sorry
what did Blake honestly do wrong up
there because we did not see hands
shaking at the end it wasn't a Blake
forgiveness story tonight unfortunately
the things that Blake said I was the
same advice I gave him while he was in
paradise it was like quick with the but
part of the sentence say the first part
leave it there and people will respect
you they they know you're not a bad guy
you just did some stupid stuff I think
he just kept digging his hole deeper and
deeper and deeper instead of you know
letting it be where he is stepping out
of it moving on it was it was hard to
watch I don't know if you guys have been
in touch you know there's a group taxi
it seems like Blake had maybe gone kind
of dark like had you talked too much in
the past couple months I've talked to
Blake a little bit in the past few
months just to say look we love you we
know you're not a bad person and give
support you know I I wasn't aware that
he was gonna release the text messages
but I definitely would have said the
same thing it sounds like everybody said
which is don't but you know I think he's
got some growth to go through and I
have full faith that he actually will
you think he can grow from here
I definitely think Blake can grow from
here let's talk about some drama you had
that was pretty unexpected John Paul
Jones versus Derek two people we did not
think would fight in Paradise things
don't seem like they got resolved
tonight where are you guys at I mean
things were absolutely resolved there
was really yeah John himself on camera
said that he didn't have truth he didn't
have proof Dylan himself said that the
conversation John continues to reference
was not what John said and so I think
that right there is complete vindication
for me on feeling good about the fact
that at least you know look I know where
my character is all of my friends on
that stage knew and that this was purely
someone who seems to still be jealous
and can't let go of something that's a
very good point I guess I met resolved
like are you two gonna walk away okay
with each other or no words between you
and JPJ from here anybody who would take
it upon themselves to fabricate things
like that about someone it's not the
kind of person that I ever associate
with so no John what was that fight like
for you in the moment watching it he
seems like a different person kind of
unhinged I thought at first we were
gonna sit down and have a nice
conversation I don't know if you noticed
that but I was like yeah dude let's
let's go talk so I felt like I was
driving along in a truck hit me was very
unprepared for any of that and it's just
so weird to watch back but also again in
clips ahead of time while we've really
seen is him talking it was really nice
to see that it was a balanced
conversation you see my attempt at
clear-headedness in the face of someone
who was basically victimizing himself
and speaking for somebody else speaking
over you what was that like
no no Derek Derek yeah also well you
know what I guess for the record are you
somebody who hooks up with fans who
listen to your podcast and DM you
officially I have never hooked up with a
podcast fan ever
that is on the record you heard it here
absolutely not
JPJ was making some stuff up about you
absolutely everything was completely
made up and again Dylan echoed that
tonight that there was the conversation
that he continues to reference was by
the way a question that John asked me
and was not at all what he said so more
reality TV in the future for you another
round at Paradise I've got my nice happy
9 to 5 Lauren I'm Andrew podcast and
yeah that's my nice actually you know I
love doing that because it's it's like
my creative aspect I get to get out I'm
in finance and its own numbers focused
and and so in you know in my head all
day long it's nice to be able to chat in
gossip with people would you have done
the bachelor gig if the offer had come
your way I personally I actually think
it's ridiculous that people say no to
this
that's a as long as you're sure with who
you are and sure yourself I think you
should always say yes to that question
what type of woman are you looking for
okay I think I think it's very clear
just looking at the season of paradise
that Taoiseach Demi like they're very
transparent they speak their mind
they're not afraid to say something that
they disagree with it and that's like a
somebody who isn't isn't run over by my
personality is like the number one thing
that I look for I mean you were
attracted to Demi how happy are you to
see her with somebody else you handled
this with so much grace it's not even
funny I'm so happy for Demi and she
knows that I've said that so many times
and to Christian as well you know the
two of them are very beautiful people
and they're amazing and will be part of
my life forever so I'm very happy for
her you know who's a strong woman as our
executive producer Aaron Johnson so I'm
just gonna say maybe you two might want
to meet up I don't know who Aaron is but
it's great she's blonde she's beautiful
she's very independent and intelligent I
think she's the one all right
on a date
[Laughter]
[Music]